this crying woman
isn't crying at all and a baby will
start to cry
she's what's known as a baby wrangler
someone whose job it is to get the best
performances
out of the youngest actors this is just
one of the many surprising positions you
will find on a movie or tv set
there are people who train insects style
food and even design clothes for
animated films
these jobs are essential to making
movies work
let's take a look behind the scenes at 8
jobs and movies you may not have known
existed
it's not only real actors who need
costume designers
but animated characters as well at pixar
there are people who are specifically
hired to animate clothing
like tailoring and simulation artist
chris campbell
they have to design and model clothes
and then make sure they fit on the
animated characters
this process involves computer
simulations to make sure the fabric
moves correctly in coco for example
these simulations helped them prevent
clothes from getting stuck in the
skeleton character's bones
campbell's work throughout the years
prepared him for onward
however he wasn't just animating clothes
this time
in this film the item of clothing was a
character
acting out how the animated characters
move in real life can provide
reference when the animators in onward
needed to figure out how a floating pair
of pants would behave
they put someone in a green suit and a
pair of khaki pants
and observed what it would look like to
see somebody walking around who was
missing the top half of their body
while a clothing animator focuses on
clothing they still have a great
understanding of how every aspect of
animation
works dad's upper half and onward had
no muscle underneath making simulations
much more challenging so campbell relied
on a simulation
created for characters with volume which
was originally used for the squishy
movements of hank the
octopus in finding dory and they need to
add
small details to clothes that you would
normally expect to see
like little threads hanging off a
sweater a vital but unexpected part of
the job
shading lighting can help textures look
more realistic
which can sell the whole look this is
the reason why dad's vest looks
naturally puffy
instead of plastic
productions try to use real food
whenever they can
and when they do a food stylist comes in
to handle it all it's a lot more than
just
altering dishes to fit an actor's
dietary restrictions
though that is certainly part of the job
food stylist zoe hegedouch had to solve
a number of different problems on the
set of midsamar
the film was mostly shot outdoors in the
heat
so she had to make sure the food both
looked and stayed
fresh sometimes this was as easy as
spraying a potato with cooking spray
to make it look like it just came out of
the oven other dishes needed to be
altered entirely to beat the heat
for example those meat pies you see on
screen
aren't filled with real meat which would
spoil quickly
instead hegga douche cooked oatmeal and
colored it brown
giving it the look and texture of
chopped meat
she also had to plate a lot of eggs for
the sun's eye dish that was prominently
featured during one of the film's mini
feasts
first she tried making some real eggs
but the yolks kept exploding
meaning she and her team had to swap the
dishes out every 15 minutes
plus work days could last 10 to 12 hours
so there was a risk of them drying out
instead
she decided to make this mixture out of
orange and mango juice
and shaped it to look exactly like real
yolks
and what does a food stylist do when
they have to find an item that's not
even available where they're filming
for one pivotal moment they needed to
have a fresh herring
which is abundant in sweden but not so
much in hungary where the movie was shot
the fish had to be real in order to get
this horrified reaction from florence
pugh
eventually she had to get 20 pieces of
herring shipped in from france
meaning they had only 20 tries to get it
right
luckily they nailed it after seven or
eight tries
some foods are just too difficult to use
the real thing on set
for example real ice cream would melt
too quickly
or maybe you need a lot of food to sit
in the background of a shot
in these instances a fake food artist is
essential
this scene in glee was set in a diner
and called for lots of ice cream sundaes
milkshakes and banana splits on the
tables and counters
fake versions were needed so they would
appear fresh and new the entire time
fake food artist brenda chapman made a
variety of these desserts
which were set at various stages of
being eaten when someone like lisa
friedman needs to make fake food
she'll first get a real version of the
food she needs to recreate
then she makes a mold of that item she
pours a mixture of rubber and
foam into that same mold to create the
shape
but it isn't until the item is
hand-painted that it starts to look like
the real thing
aside from being a great painter being a
fake food artist means getting creative
with the materials
to make granola and ground beef friedman
took corkboard
and crushed it giving her just the right
texture
sometimes a character will need
different looking eyes than the
performer portraying them
such as hugh jackman's bloodshot eyes
and les miserables
in these cases they'll go somewhere like
eyeworks for film in london
putting contacts on can completely
change the color of an actor's eyes
it can also make them look older or even
like another species
first the designer will get a brief
description of the character
then they'll research what the look
should look like develop
concept art and then finally check the
actors eyes to fit the contacts for them
in order for the contacts to feel normal
and natural to wear
director of eye works for film sinead
sweeney
says the contacts they design have to
sit directly on top of the cornea
they have to make lenses of all shapes
and sizes
sometimes the lenses they make are much
bigger than the average pupil
the trick to getting them on as eyeworks
told insider
put your chin up and turn your eyes to
the left
working with bugs on camera is no easy
feat
but yes you can train an insect to act
getting bugs to move in the right
direction involves playing with light
air and room temperature entomologist
stephen kutcher can get
all kinds of bugs to perform on camera
for spider-man and arachnophobia
he was hired to wrangle the film's
spiders for one shot in arachnophobia
a spider needed to crawl across the
floor and into a slipper
so kutcher devised a clever trick using
invisible vibrating wires
by playing around with these kucher
could get the spiders directly where
they needed to go
when working on spider-man kutcher had
to get a spider to descend from a web
and then onto toby maguire's hand
where it could deliver the fateful bite
kutcher decided to stand above maguire
while holding a paintbrush
the spider crawled along the paintbrush
until it reached the
end at that point kutcher tapped the
brush
and the spider dropped down he faced an
even bigger challenge in
exorcist 2 the heretic he had to train
3 000 locusts which needed to cling onto
the screened wall of a cage
however most of these locusts stood on
the floor in order to drive them onto
the walls
he took a heat-emitting light and shined
it against the cage
and the locus subsequently flocked
towards it
when a sex scene is filmed for a movie
or tv show
it is crucial that the actors feel
protected and not
violated on set for this reason the role
of intimacy coordinator which is
relatively new to hollywood
has proven to be essential an intimacy
coordinator like eda o'brien
is tasked with coaching actors on sex
and love scenes
the most crucial part of her job is
making sure these moments are done
safely and with clear consent during
this time
the motivations behind these scenes are
clearly established
o'brien worked with the cast of the
netflix series sex education
she had to make sure the cast was safe
and prepared for the show's intimate
moments
for these scenes she created cushions
and flesh-colored articles of clothing
these items gave the cast the ability to
cover themselves
as well as an extra barrier of
protection during the simulated sex
scenes
babies don't always cry on command so
when you need one to wail on camera
that's when you bring in a professional
elaine hall is a baby wrangler but she
also describes herself as an
interpreter unlike with adult actors
babies can only be on set for a limited
amount of time
as they can only legally work for four
hours a day
this means that hall needs to get babies
to master their scenes in as few
takes as possible she has many tricks
for how to do this
if she needs to make a young actor look
happy in a scene
she might attach a funny-looking face to
the camera lens
but what about making a baby cry like
she did for a scene in akilah and the
bee
well she got really really involved and
even started sobbing herself according
to hall
when the baby heard her crying the baby
immediately started crying herself
then to get the baby to stop paul
stopped crying
and reassured the baby that everything
was okay
oh and objects like a rattle or a bell
also help
while actors are sometimes given rubber
swords especially for really dangerous
stunts
there are times when they need real
weapons for utmost authenticity on
camera
enter blacksmith tony swatin who's
worked on over 200 movies
yes he is a real blacksmith who makes
actual
functioning swords for hollywood
swatten's weapons look great in
close-ups and give the actors the
feeling of holding a real weapon which
in turn makes their performances
even better his job isn't as easy as
just creating any old weapon out of
metal
he needs to be really accurate to match
the setting
for instance when he worked on the mask
of zorro he created a curved hunting
blade
that would have been used in the 1500s
for antonio banderas
besides being hyper-specific he also
needs to make multiple versions of a
weapon for different purposes
for example while he will make a steel
sword for close-ups
swords made out of aluminum are better
for sequences involving action
and actual sword fights you can see here
with the steel blade swanton made for
johnny depp and pirates of the caribbean
swatin has worked on some movies that
involved large battle sequences
like the last samurai for that he wasn't
just making weapons for tom cruise
he also had to make about 600 aluminum
blades for all of the extras
in the biggest battle scenes
thanks for watching it takes a whole lot
of talented people to make
your favorite movies what other movies
would you like to learn more about
let us know in the comments